mais d'abord les musées et châteaux
confronté un nouveau casse-tête leur
fermeture ne plombe pas seulement leurs
recettes
elle affecte aussi leurs collections
faute de visiteurs et donc de brassage
d'air l'humidité s'installe et c'est
très mauvais pour certaines pièces au
château de blois on redouble de
vigilance
audrey champigny françois 1er lui-même
serait probablement resté de marbre son
château fourmis lyon d'ordinaire de
visiteurs est aujourd'hui désert et ses
trésors se dégrade
les salles sont moins aéré et l'humidité
s'installe le fait qu'on a eu une
condamnation importante on avait des
gouttelettes sur les vitres des vitrines
et même sur sur les boiseries ici dans
le studio de la reine catherine de
médicis de l'ivoire et de l'émail datant
du xvième siècle sont des matériaux qui
n'aime pas les grandes modifications de
température vous avoir un soulèvement de
l'émail
en plus de l'or ça peut se sauver il
voir c'est encore plus ennuyeux parce
que l'ivoire est un matériau extrêmement
fragile qui peut se fendiller et à ce
moment là il ya quasiment rien à faire
jamais le monument n'avait connu une
fermeture si importante depuis le 19e
siècle alors on met à profit ce temps
pour réaménager des pièces et mettre en
lumière des collections jamais vus par
le public
maryse et christelle elles sont
d'habitude chargé d'accueillir les
visiteurs depuis fin janvier elles ont
été formées pour faire du récolement
autrement dit l'inventaire des trésors
du château un travail passionnant
la fédé napoléon les différents empires
les pièces sont tellement belles avec
lui il ya des gravières qui sont
vraiment très intéressante puis on voit
suivant les époques les matières aussi
puisque ça change matières
systématiquement tout ça ça nous apprend
des matières comprenez c'est ma part des
fois on est surpris parce que là il y en
a une de cochinchine vieux voilier
pierce étant étrangère aussi donc c'est
intéressant de
voir on va chercher la cause la chine
sait où le château qui accueille en ce
moment plusieurs tournages de fiction
espère ouvrir ses portes prochainement
chaque année il comptabilise environ
quatre cent mille visiteurs